y
[Música]
hola les doy la bienvenida a kobe 19 la
semana en américa al espacio de france
24 y hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con el cob y
19 en nuestro continente a continuación
les presento algunos de los temas
destacados para el programa de hoy
de acuerdo con cifras de la oms son
cerca de 15 millones de personas las que
han fallecido desde que comenzó la
pandemia el organismo dice que la cifra
puede ser unas 3 veces mayor debido a
que al inicio de la emergencia sanitaria
no hubo acceso completo a las pruebas
para determinar si los pacientes tenían
coronavirus o no vamos a analizar el
tema en unos minutos también hablaremos
sobre las sub variantes de apuntó cuatro
y vea punto 5 derivadas de la variante
omicron cerca de 20 países ya han
reportado varios casos los expertos
estiman que cada 11 días aparece una
nueva sub variante de ese modo entonces
estaríamos ante el virus con la
propagación más rápida de la historia de
la humanidad y otro tema la fed ya en
eeuu puso límite a la autorización del
uso de emergencia de la vacuna contra el
jove y 19 que es producida por johnson y
johnson por la farmacéutica janssen la
restricción regirá para personas de 18
años o para quienes tengan otras vacunas
que es no no en ese caso no son
apropiadas ante el riesgo de desarrollar
condiciones peligrosas de coagulación
vamos a comenzar y lo hacemos como es
habitual con cifras actualizándonos en
cuanto al número de casos y de
fallecidos hoy vamos a hacer énfasis en
territorios insulares de nuestro
continente del continente americano les
va a traer unos territorios muy exóticos
para ver cuántas personas hay allí
contagiadas con kobe 19 en los últimos
28 días vamos a conversar a comenzar en
bermudas en el atlántico allí han
reportado 121 mil 121 casos nuevos
solamente dos personas han fallecido en
los últimos 28 días un poco más al sur
puerto rico- allí fueron reportados 71
mil 525 nuevos casos 51 personas han
fallecido en la parte sur del caribe en
trinidad y tobago allí han sido
reportados en los últimos 28 días cerca
de 10 mil
355 casos 72 personas han fallecido y
nos vamos hasta el extremo sur a las
islas malvinas así fueron contabilizados
69 casos de kobe 19 en los últimos 28
días y no han reportado víctimas
mortales
y ya son más de 15 millones de víctimas
mortales las que deja el coronavirus
desde que comenzó la emergencia
sanitaria lado ms afirmó que la cifra
podría ser tres veces mayor a la que ha
sido reportada debido a que contabilizar
las víctimas ha sido complicado y
también porque al inicio de la
emergencia entre las limitaciones que
hubo hubo muchas dificultades para poder
acceder a las pruebas de pcr por lo que
muchos pacientes fallecieron sin haber
sido diagnosticados a ciencia cierta con
kobe 19 veamos
un nuevo informe publicado por la
organización mundial de la salud estimó
este jueves el verdadero número de
muertos de la pandemia en el mundo en 15
millones de personas casi tres veces más
de lo que muestran los datos oficiales y
que el 68 por ciento del exceso de
muertes se concentra en sólo 10 países
a nivel mundial estimamos un exceso de
14,9 millones de muertes asociadas a la
pandemia de kobe 19 para el 31 de
diciembre de 2021
hay 5,4 millones de muertes por kobe 19
notificadas a la ms durante este periodo
por lo tanto esta estimación de exceso
representa 95 millones de muertes más o
275 veces más de las muertes reportadas
el informe señala que casi la mitad de
las muertes no contabilizadas se
produjeron en india donde se
contabilizaron 47 millones de muertos 10
veces más que las cifras oficiales
aunque el gobierno indio ha cuestionado
la metodología el organismo sanitario
también pidió mejores datos diciendo que
los países deberán invertir en la
vigilancia de la mortalidad para prever
futuras crisis y proporcionar las cifras
exactas de
los datos son en efecto el alma de la
salud pública el que ha sacado a la luz
una cifra asombrosa ya que hemos visto
14.9 millones de muertes en exceso pero
también ha sacado a la luz asombrosas
lagunas en los datos de los países que
encontréis estas estimaciones también
tienen en cuenta las muertes causadas
por las consecuencias del cob y 19 como
servicios sanitarios desbordados la
escasez de pruebas al comienzo de la
pandemia y los malos registros en
algunas partes del mundo pero la ms
específico que la mayoría de las muertes
adicionales se debieron directamente al
virus
un momento para nuestra habitual
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo y asesor
científico de france 24 a quien
saludamos hasta ahora en la ciudad de
bogotá en colombia doctor pérez como
siempre un gusto conversar con usted
comienza nuestra consulta con la noticia
destacada esta semana y son esas nuevas
variantes que han surgido en los últimos
días vea punto 4.5 ya hay casos
detectados en américa y en áfrica que se
sabe al respecto
sin como era de esperarse estas
variantes van surgiendo en personas que
no se han vacunado o que han perdido la
inmunidad y es muy frecuente que estas
variantes como pasa en este tipo de
virus sucedan y van a seguir sucediendo
lo que llama la atención de estos es que
aumentan su capacidad de
transmisibilidad es decir que es un
virus y con crema de contagioso tal vez
los más contagiosos que conozcamos en la
humanidad y que infectan a personas
sobre todo susceptibles personas que
pierden la inmunidad o que no han estado
vacunas pero no se ha demostrado que
sean que produzca una enfermedad más
grave son más contagiosos todavía no se
sabe si más virulentos y afecten en
población no inmunizada
doctor otra cifra destacada esta semana
a partir de varios estudios publicados
el 13 por ciento de las personas que han
sido hospitalizadas por kobe 19 tienen
síntomas neurológicos graves de qué
síntomas estamos hablando cuál es la
incidencia que tiene el cob y 19 en la
parte neurológica
el como hemos hablado es una
enfermedad infecciosa pero termina
siendo una enfermedad inflamatoria está
informada esa enfermedad inflamatoria
cuando es un compromiso severo inflama
el cerebro y eso se llama encefalitis y
ese daño ese pánico que se produce por
esa inflamación produce alteraciones
neurológicas
inmediatas por ejemplo con alteraciones
de números compulsivos alteración del
estado de conciencia y el contenido de
la conciencia y otros que pueden ser
secuelas como hemos visto en pacientes
que han tenido amnesia pérdida de la
memoria defectos en habilidades
neurológicas pérdidas de concentración
esto por ese daño cerebral que sea sobre
todo en personas que tienen infecciones
severas y que compromete en varios
órganos la enfermedad esa inflamación
del cerebro es encefalitis sucede de 10
a 15 por ciento de las personas que se
hospitalizan sobre todo en unidades de
woking doctor le transmite una de las
preguntas que hemos recibido a través de
las redes sociales de nuestros
televidentes preguntan si afectaría
nuestro sistema inmunitario una cuarta
dosis de vacunación
países las autoridades sanitarias se
están discutiendo sobre este tema
también las farmacéuticas están viendo
la viabilidad en cuanto al suministro de
las vacunas para para todos los países
alrededor del mundo pero a nivel de
nuestro organismo cómo puede reaccionar
estas cuartas dosis
no van a afectar el sistema inmune si
pensamos que va a funcionar efecto
deletéreo el sistema inmunológico lo que
hemos visto en la respuesta en estas
vacunas de primera generación es que la
respuesta dura seis meses no más allá de
12 meses por eso si va a ser necesario y
ya se está estableciendo en varios
países un segundo refuerzo que es esa
cuarta dosis no tiene efectos deletéreos
en algunas personas menores de 50 años
se inmunocompetentes todavía no está
claro qué beneficios trae pero en
personas mayores de 50 años y sobre todo
personas independientemente de la edad
que tengan enfermedades que afecten su
sistema inmune es necesario ese segundo
refuerzo es probable santiago que
nosotros tengamos la pauta de esta
vacunación cada seis meses o anualmente
estamos por establecer si con estas
vacunas de primera generación o con una
reformulación de ellas pero la inmunidad
se pierde no afecta al sistema inmune y
muy probablemente recreamos una cuarta y
después la quinta a veces sin que eso
afecte o produzca enfermedad doctor para
el cierre hablemos de la salud mental
hay cifras preocupantes que ha dado la
ope s en cuanto a los casos de depresión
están aumentando los casos porque el cob
it produce depresión
si lo que comentábamos ese daño
encefálico produce alteración de la
esfera mental pero también en el coach
se unen otros factores como fue el
aislamiento la pérdida de familiares el
duelo prolongado la falta de interacción
social que ha hecho que la salud mental
sea realmente un gran problema en la
post pandemia nos preocupa no solamente
la depresión sino el incremento en el
número de suicidios y también la
afectación que tiene en población joven
con deserción escolar de sesión
universitaria que también es una gran
preocupación yo creo que uno de los
grandes problemas y desafíos es cómo
vamos a enfrentar la salud mental en la
post pandemia y eso no es una decisión
de un gobierno es personal familiar
social medios de comunicación y toda la
sociedad para que podamos salir adelante
en una patología que es supremamente
difícil de manejar y de identificar es
un trabajo en conjunto doctor muchísimas
gracias por esta consulta aquí en kobe
19 la semana en américa a continuación
les presento el número de dosis de
refuerzo que fueron inoculadas por cada
100 habitantes en una serie de países al
azar en nuestro continente demos un
vistazo entonces a méxico allí han
inoculado 37 puntos 0 5 dosis de
refuerzo por cada 100 habitantes en las
islas de bahamas solamente 70 dos dosis
por cada 100 habitantes en jamaica el 10
6% de dosis por cada 100 habitantes en
trinidad y tobago el
10,78 de dosis de refuerzo ha sido
inoculadas por cada 100 habitantes y en
toda américa del sur sólo el 38 61 el
número de dosis por cada 100 habitantes
en todo este territorio
nos vamos a ir ahora hasta santiago en
chile para conocer las novedades que hay
en ese país que cuenta con una alta tasa
de vacunación también hay una reducción
de los casos y el gobierno ya decretó la
apertura de las fronteras vamos a
conocer entonces el balance con el
periodista leonardo honores leonardo
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
el programa y comenzó por la vacunación
por ese proceso que se ha mantenido
constante rápido pero hay algunos
retrasos en cuanto a la población
escolar y también preocupa la población
que es vulnerable a problemas
respiratorios porque el invierno está
por comenzar aquí en suramérica la
situación de la pandemia en chile está
marcada entre otras cosas por los
cambios de temperatura la llegada
específicamente del otoño y esto también
ha ido de la mano de diferencias y
lentitud es justamente dentro del
proceso de vacunación en las últimas
semanas en los últimos días ha habido un
incremento importante respecto de los
nuevos casos de acogida y esto preocupa
a las autoridades ya que hay que
recordar hace ya prácticamente dos meses
se retomaron las clases presenciales en
las escuelas y esto ha generado un
factor de riesgo adicional porque entre
otras cosas convivirá el coi con
enfermedades estacionarias como la
influenza las autoridades sanitarias
aquí en chile han puesto un énfasis
especial en el proceso de vacunación de
la población en edad escolar
específicamente en los más pequeños
entre los 6 y los 11 años la primera
etapa de primaria y también en algunos
casos la medianía de la secundaria
específicamente el 60% aproximadamente
de la población total en chile está
vacunada con al menos la tercera dosis
de aquí en adelante queda el riesgo eso
sí y la duda respecto de cuánto avanzará
este proceso una vez que ya esté el
invierno en marcha aquí en nuestro país
con oscilaciones térmicas y también con
la mayor preocupación que se ha
planteado de parte de las autoridades es
que podría ser un año especialmente poco
lluvioso lo que podría tener un impacto
negativo también en la estacionalidad de
las enfermedades esa es la situación
hasta el minuto aquí en el chile
específicamente respecto de la pandemia
leonardo recientemente en las
autoridades de chilé abrieron nuevamente
las fronteras del país cuál es el
balance que hacen de esta medida
efectivamente hay preocupación respecto
de lo que puede ocurrir también con el
proceso de apertura de las fronteras
específicamente esto ya se ha dado curso
hace algunas semanas y hace se ha
comprobado un fuerte incremento de el
flujo comercial la gran cantidad incluso
de turistas que en algunos casos ha
vuelto al país en la zona norte en el
límite de chile con perú ha habido uno
de los flujos más importantes
tradicionalmente entre las ciudades de
arica y tacna se produce un intercambio
importante tanto comercial como de
personas y allí también hay un foco de
preocupación porque específicamente esta
ciudad la ciudad fronteriza de arica ha
tenido un retroceso dentro del plan paso
a paso que entre otras cosas significa
mayores restricciones en el marco de la
pandemia y si hablamos de actividades
por ejemplo hay preocupación respecto de
lo que ha ocurrido con las actividades
específicamente culturales las grandes
aglomeraciones por ejemplo los grandes
conciertos el más reciente el de
metallica que congregó a cerca de 60.000
personas de allí en adelante también que
hay un foco especial de parte de las
autoridades sobre lo que puede ocurrir
en materia sanitaria producto justamente
del avance de la pandemia y por cierto
el factor migratorio
leonardo hablamos con el doctor pérez
sobre el tema de la salud mental en
chile- también hay un aumento en el
número de ataques de ansiedad entre la
comunidad de personas adultas también en
ataques de trastornos de conducta entre
los menores de edad allí en chile- que
dicen las autoridades que cifras hay al
respecto
ese es otro de los elementos que
preocupa mucho aquí en chile el factor
que ha tenido el impacto que ha tenido
la pandemia respecto de la salud mental
de los chilenos y chilenas la cantidad
de consultas psicológicas psiquiátricas
ha aumentado exponencialmente
en el último tiempo y también se ha
generado una situación tremendamente
compleja que es la disponibilidad
justamente de doctores de especialistas
para poder atender la alta demanda se ha
visto en jaque eso también ha complicado
muchísimo la situación aquí en chile la
salud justamente mental ha revelado
muchas cosas que se habían escondido
producto de las cuarentenas el
confinamiento entre otras cosas por
ejemplo se ha traducido esto en la
extensión en las aulas en los colegios
se han registrado nuevos hechos de
violencia es algo preocupa de
sobremanera a las autoridades aquí en
chile
leonardo muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de santiago en chile ya
lo decíamos distintos estudios han
demostrado que la pandemia de kobe 19 ha
elevado los niveles de casos reportados
y episodios de ansiedad y depresión en
el mundo entero las cifras han alertado
a los sistemas de salud de los países
sobre la importancia de mejorar los
sistemas de atención de salud mental en
la región veamos
en el primer año de la pandemia la
prevalencia mundial de la ansiedad y la
depresión aumentó un 25 por ciento según
un informe científico publicado por la
organización mundial de la salud este
aumento afectó más a las mujeres y a los
jóvenes especialmente los que tenían
entre 20 y 24 años algo con lo que
coincidió amy tauste consultora de salud
mental de la organización panamericana
de la salud quien a través de un estudio
llegó a la conclusión que en 2020 el 27
por ciento de los adolescentes y jóvenes
encuestados en américa latina y caribe
declararon sentir ansiedad y el 15 por
ciento depresión en efecto la ope se
alertó de una pandemia de salud mental
simultánea a la de kobe 19
mientras estamos atravesando una
pandemia que sigue afectando a nuestra
región con casos de enfermedad y muertes
hemos visto una pandemia simultánea de
salud mental que ha sido abiertamente
reconocida en la región
los datos analizados por este organismo
muestran que más de 4 de cada 10
leños han tenido problemas de ansiedad y
seis de cada diez de depresión en perú
los síntomas de depresión se
quintuplicaron a raíz de la pandemia en
canadá los niveles de ansiedad se
cuadruplicaron y en eeuu las tasas de
ansiedad y depresión alcanzaron hasta el
37 y el 30 por ciento respectivamente a
finales de 2020 frente al 8,1 por ciento
y el 6,5 por ciento respectivamente en
2019 los expertos atribuyen estos
problemas mentales al encierro al miedo
a la infección al sufrimiento y a la
muerte así como a las preocupaciones
económicas de otra parte el agotamiento
fue una de las principales causas de los
pensamientos suicidas entre el personal
sanitario así lo determinó un estudio
liderado por las universidades de chile
y de columbia en colaboración con la opc
en la que 14.500 dos trabajadores
sanitarios de 11 países americanos
fueron encuestados
el informe de de kobe nightingale care
workers muestra que entre el 14 7% y el
22% del personal de salud entrevistado
en 2020 presentó síntomas que permitían
sospechar un episodio depresivo mientras
que entre un 5 y 15 por ciento del
personal dijo que pensó en suicidarse
en efecto el 90% de los países
encuestados han incluido la salud mental
y el apoyo psicosocial a sus planes de
respuesta al cob y 19 previo a la
emergencia sanitaria se estimaba que de
no ser incorporados en los sistemas de
salud le costarían a la economía mundial
unos 16 mil millones de dólares para el
año 2030
ahora hablamos de argentina vamos a
conocer detalles de cómo está la
situación en ese país para eso
conectamos con natalia cosoi
corresponsal de france 24 en la ciudad
de buenos aires la capital argentina
hola natalio gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa comienzo
preguntándole por el llamado que
hicieron las autoridades argentinas para
aumentar el ritmo de la vacunación entre
los ciudadanos qué es lo que pasa
en argentina más del 80% de la población
tiene al menos dos dosis de vacuna
contra kobe 19 según los datos oficiales
la idea es dar lo antes posible un
refuerzo a quienes aún no lo han
recibido hasta ahora son 18 millones
algo más de 18 millones de personas las
que tienen un refuerzo de esta vacuna
sobre una población aproximada de 45
millones de habitantes además se están
aplicando dosis adicionales a personas
con mayor riesgo sería una cuarta dosis
personas con más exposición tal vez con
comorbilidades mayores de cierta edad es
algo que se acordó en el consejo federal
de salud a mediados de abril donde se
reúnen los ministros de salud de todas
las provincias de argentina y de de la
nación para para impulsar esta
vacunación y además continúa la
insistencia de las autoridades para que
aquellos que no iniciaron su esquema de
vacunación o no completaron las dos
dosis iniciales traten de hacerlo lo
antes posible además de incentivar ahora
con la llegada de los fríos la
vacunación antigripal en aquellas
poblaciones en aquellos grupos
a los que les corresponda a tomar esa
vacuna también
natalio preocupa mucho que hay un
aumento de caso significativo allí en
argentina y también preocupa la
población que puede estar expuesta a
problemas respiratorios porque estamos a
menos de un mes y medio para el inicio
del invierno que dicen las autoridades
cuál es la situación allí
la verdad que después de persistentes
bajas en abril a mediados de abril
comenzaron a subir nuevamente los casos
junto con la llegada del otoño de los
primeros fríos algo en parte esperable
porque la gente empieza a reunirse más
en espacios cerrados menos ventilados
pero además hay menos testeos en mucha
gente ante los síntomas que antes lo
llevaban inmediatamente un centro de
testeo ahora tal vez deciden no ir a
testear si además hay otras enfermedades
respiratorias presentes en estos días
aquí y existe la sospecha de algunos
especialistas de que tal vez además haya
un subregistro de casos de kobe 19 ahora
en argentina desde el gobierno esperan
que este incremento este alza de casos
no se traduzca en un alza importante en
las internaciones y sobre todo en los
fallecimientos que no ocurra lo que
ocurrió en anteriores olas de kobe 19
aquí en argentina por eso apuesta muy
fuerte e insiste mucho como decía antes
en la vacunación en que aquellos que no
comenzaron su esquema lo comiencen y
quienes no lo completaron los completen
y quienes necesitan refuerzos que se el
refuerzo lo antes posible y por último
natalia repasemos qué medidas se
mantienen vigentes allí en argentina
la realidad es que hoy en día
prácticamente no hay
restricciones la vida es realmente lo
más parecido a la normalidad en todo
caso lo que hay son recomendaciones las
mismas de siempre la insistencia en
intentar usar cubrebocas sobre todo en
espacios cerrados tratar de no reunirse
masivamente o en grandes grupos en
espacios muy cerrados y mal ventilados y
tratar en la medida de lo posible de
ventilar los ambientes algo que es más
difícil ahora cuando llegan los fríos
por eso la preocupación en el uso del
cubrebocas hoy en día es muy aleatorio
no se ve todo el tiempo de gente que lo
usa en exteriores en interiores hay
gente que no lo usa en ningún lugar han
regresado argentinas a costumbres muy de
aquí como bueno en saludarse con un beso
incluso entre entre varones que no es
algo común en otras partes del mundo de
américa latina' los abrazos del darse la
mano incluso en algunos casos en el
compartir el mate la bebida típica de
argentina que serían considerados
comportamientos de riesgo hay que ver si
de la mano de un incremento de los casos
comienzan a regresar también prácticas
de mayor cuidado las que insisten y
piden que se cumplan en la medida de lo
posible las autoridades del país natalio
muchas gracias por este reporte desde
buenos aires en argentina cambiamos de
tema en su informe anual sobre la
libertad de prensa la organización
reporteros sin fronteras reveló que la
pandemia del coronavirus contribuyó a
acelerar en 2021 la censura en américa
latina' la ong destacó que la crisis
sanitaria provocó graves dificultades
económicas para la prensa también algo
que repercutió en el acceso a la
información los países que más
retrocedieron fueron brasil el salvador
venezuela nicaragua y cuba méxico
continúa siendo el país más mortífero
para los periodistas costa rica-
permanece como el país más seguro de la
región para ejercer la profesión de
periodista
y vamos a seguir en américa del sur nos
vamos ahora hasta venezuela para conocer
detalles de la situación en ese país
hace mucho tiempo que no recibíamos
actualización e información de ese país
por eso saludamos a daniela zambrano
corresponsal de france 24 que se
encuentra en la ciudad de caracas hola
daniela gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa primero conozcamos el
panorama general actualice monos en
cuanto a la situación en materia
epidemiológica casos vacunados y
personas fallecidas
hola santiago que tal gusto en saludarte
según datos del ministerio del poder
popular para la salud de venezuela en
este momento el país registra el índice
más bajo de contagios de kobe 19 desde
el inicio de la pandemia un dato
importante en el mes de abril por
primera vez en más de 2 años se registró
durante varios días consecutivos cero
fallecidos por ccoo y 19 y este parece
ser una tendencia que se mantiene hasta
el momento del último boletín daba
cuenta de más de 522 mil casos positivos
de kobe 19 las personas recuperadas
superan las 515 mil y lamentablemente la
cifra de fallecidos que maneja el
gobierno cinco mil 709 personas hasta la
fecha sin embargo hay algo importante y
es que esta cifra difiere mucho de la
presentada por la organización mundial
de la salud que daba cuenta que al
cierre de 2021 en venezuela se habían
registrado más de 22.000 fallecimientos
relacionados con la enfermedad del cob y
19 ellos incluyen cifras no reportadas y
también personas que no tuvieron acceso
oportuno al tratamiento por el colapso
del sistema
precisamente por la pandemia algo
singular pasa con el proceso de
vacunación en febrero el gobierno a
nicolás madura habladas que
prácticamente el cien por ciento de la
población ya había recibido las dos
dosis de vacuna contra kobe 19 sin
embargo para el mínimo la organización
panamericana de la salud reportaba que
sólo el 49.9 por ciento de la población
en venezuela había recibido las dos
dosis de vacunas contra kobe 19
precisamente esta última semana y la
organización transparencia venezuela
hace un informe en el que hablaba de la
opacidad y las contradicciones en las
cifras que maneja el gobierno con
respecto a la pandera
daniela me parece pertinente hacer un
repaso por las restricciones las medidas
que se mantienen allí vigentes en
venezuela para hacer frente a la
pandemia
desde que principios de año el gobierno
venezolano decidió flexibilizar
prácticamente todas las normas que se
han impuesto para precisamente evitar la
propagación de la pandemia en kobe 19
esta situación se ha mantenido lo que sí
siendo sigue siendo obligatorio es el
uso de mascarillas en lugares cerrados
iglesias centros educativos centros de
salud centros comerciales entre otros
con respecto a los aeropuertos
prácticamente todos los aeropuertos
habían cerrado en venezuela durante la
pandemia y hace dos meses instituto
nacional de aeronáutica civil permitió
la reanudación de los vuelos nacionales
que se mantenían cerrados precisamente
por la pandemia pero esto bajo
supervisión también se han incorporado
nuevas rutas internacionales recordemos
que venezuela estaba bastante
restringidas por situación económica
pero también por pandemias se han
incorporado nuevas rutas en el último
mes como españa y portugal y el próximo
mes espero también renovación de vuelos
con chile sigue siendo obligatorio
además al aterrizar en el aeropuerto
internacional de maiquetía que los
ciudadanos se sometan a una prueba de
kobe 19 esas son las restricciones que
se mantienen
daniela recientemente aquí en france 24
en el programa enlace a usted presentó
un informe sobre el aumento de la
censura en venezuela a raíz de la
pandemia de kobe 19 cómo está el
panorama informativo allí en venezuela
después de esta crisis sanitaria
en las últimas semanas se han presentado
varios informes al respecto uno de ellos
el de espacio público que daba cuenta
que menos del 40 por ciento de los
medios de comunicación en venezuela
reportan la crisis política y económica
del país precisamente por temor a
represalias la mayoría de los medios de
comunicación están sometidos escritos
controles por parte de la comisión
nacional de telecomunicaciones el ente
regulador es otro dato importante el
ofrecía el informe debe sin filtro que
decía que durante el 2021
59 páginas web en venezuela fueron
bloqueadas 45 de ellos correspondían a
medios de comunicación la mayoría
páginas de noticias la censura contra
medios digitales e incrementados del año
2014 luego que esto se convirtiera en la
ventana que tenían los venezolanos por
informarse tras la salida del aire la
mayoría de los canales de noticias
internacionales por orden del gobierno
de nicolás maduro durante las protestas
antigubernamentales los ciudadanos hoy
en día para poder acceder a la
información tienen numerosos obstáculos
no sólo las fallas eléctricas en las
limitaciones de conexión internet sino
también las páginas bloqueadas tienen
que instalar en sus computadoras para
poder acceder entre las agresiones que
se han registrado contra periodistas en
lo que va de año siguen siendo las más
importantes de intimidación
hostigamiento y también restricciones
administrativas la detención no sólo de
periodistas sino de particulares por
difundir información también se mantiene
en venezuela el hecho más reciente y
polémico una ciudadana de 72 años
detenida luego publicar un vídeo en la
red social víctor en el que se burlaba
de nicolás maduro y otros funcionarios
del gobierno
daniela muchas gracias por este
completísimo reporte desde la ciudad de
caracas no nos vamos muy lejos nos vamos
hasta colombia un país que cuenta con
más de 50 millones de habitantes y allí
unos 6 millones de ellos han sido ya
contagiados con el cob y 19 sin embargo
el país suramericano goza de una fuerte
disminución de infecciones a lo largo de
las últimas semanas esto ha ayudado
precisamente por el alto porcentaje de
vacunación en algunos municipios esto ha
permitido a las autoridades relajar las
medidas sanitarias como por ejemplo el
uso del tapabocas o mascarilla veamos
el pasado primero de mayo el presidente
de colombia iván duque hizo un anuncio
importante desde hoy se elimina el uso
de tapabocas en municipios que hayan
aplicado 70 por ciento de esquemas
completos y 40% de dosis de refuerzo
esta medida se da gracias al avance de
nuestro plan nacional de vacunación que
ya supera los 35 5 millones de
colombianos con su inmunización completa
sin embargo el uso de la mascarilla
sigue siendo obligatorio en el
transporte público en los servicios de
salud y en los hogares geriátricos
aunque las autoridades sanitarias
sugieren que también la utilicen los
ciudadanos que presenten síntomas de
contagio a partir del 15 de mayo los
estudiantes también podrán rescindir del
tapabocas en las aulas escolares carlos
álvarez infectólogo y designado por la
organización mundial de la salud para
estudios clínicos sobre el cobo y 19 en
colombia respaldó la decisión ya que el
índice de positividad en el país
suramericano está por debajo del 5 por
ciento cifra sugerida por este organismo
para tomar medidas no farmacológicas en
este sentido en colombia el índice de
positividad está por debajo del 2o por
ciento es decir hay una baja transmisión
del virus en el país y esto se da
básicamente por el mismo hecho de la
protección con la vacunación entre tanto
las autoridades migratorias de colombia
establecieron nuevas condiciones para
ingresar al país ya sea por vía aérea o
terrestre los viajeros deberán presentar
carnet de vacunación con esquema
completo o por lo contrario mostrar una
prueba pcr realizada 72 horas antes
previas al viaje o una anti henna tomada
con 48 horas de anticipación
bueno y también hay noticias destacadas
esta semana que nos llegan desde eeuu
sobre todo anuncios en este país
superaron ya el billón de muertos por
kobe 19 a las autoridades les preocupa
que están aumentando los casos en los
últimos días en los diferentes estados
vamos entonces a conocer cómo es la
situación con mamen sala nuestra
corresponsal france24 en la ciudad de
nueva york o la mamen gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y
comienzo por esa cifra un millón de
personas fallecidas por el cob y 19 y el
aumento de los casos de contagio que
dicen allí
si en eeuu se ha superado esta semana el
millón de fallecidos por kobe 19 para
que se hagan una idea eso es el
equivalente a las mismas personas que
viven en san josé en california que es
la décima ciudad más grande de estados
unidos ha sido una cifra que se ha
alcanzado mucho más rápido de lo que se
esperaba solo han pasado 27 meses desde
que se detectó aquí en eeuu el primer
caso de coronavirus la buena noticia es
que a pesar de esta cifra las muertes y
las hospitalizaciones que son al final
las métricas que los sistemas sanitarios
utilizan están en declive ahora lo que
más preocupa es el número de infecciones
diarias que va en aumento y todo debido
a las variantes a las sub variantes de
la variante un micrón que se están
extendiendo rápidamente por todo el país
para que se hagan una idea el aumento de
contagios en las últimas dos semanas ha
sido de un 50% se trata de unas sub
variantes que son mucho más contagiosas
y como digo se están extendiendo muy
rápido por todo el país de hecho aquí en
nueva york en la ciudad nueva yor hemos
subido ya el nivel de alerta a medio y
en algunos puntos del estado de nueva
york se ha subido incluso a nivel alto
aún así las autoridades el alcalde de la
ciudad de nueva york eric adams y la
gobernadora de este estado cardiotour
han dicho que de momento no van a
imponer restricciones salvo que la
situación realmente sea muy muy muy
complicada que entonces sí que se
volvería a exigir el uso de la
mascarilla en lugares públicos
interiores pero como digo la situación
tendría que ser muy mala han dicho las
autoridades una muestra más del
agotamiento que hay ya con las
restricciones y con casi más de dos años
de pandemia
en también muy importante ese anuncio
que hizo la de fedea que restringió el
uso de la vacuna de la farmacéutica
janssen por haber sido determinado que
produce trombos en algunos casos que
explicarón allí las autoridades
sanitarias en eeuu sobre este caso
si así lo han anunciado las autoridades
sanitarias del país que esta semana han
restringido el uso de la vacuna johnson
and johnson esa vacuna de janssen de una
sola dosis porque al parecer podría ser
mortal en algunos casos provocando
coágulos de sangre según un informe que
se ha realizado revela que esta vacuna
que está dosis podría dar lugar a un
síndrome raro que se conoce como
trombosis de
trombocitopenia se trata como digo de un
síndrome raro que lo que provoca son
coágulos de sangre y disminuye los
niveles de plaquetas en sangre al
parecer y según el estudio 60 personas
dieron positivo en este síndrome y nueve
de ellas fallecieron la mayoría eran
mujeres de entre 30 y 49 años por este
motivo se ha decidido que solamente se
autorizará el uso de esta vacuna o de su
dosis de refuerzo a aquellas personas
mayores de 18 años que no tengan acceso
a otro tipo de 2 o que por algún motivo
no pudiera vacunarse si no es con la
vacuna de johnson and johnson para que
se hagan una idea hasta el momento hay
más de 19 millones de estadounidenses
que han recibido esta dosis
muchas gracias por este reporte desde la
ciudad de nueva york y con esta
información que nos llega desde eeuu
finalizamos con 1.019 la semana en
américa siga con nosotros además para
ver
[Música]